une nation divisée aux nations unies
c'est une grande première
new york 21h42 heure de paris il hier
soir l'assemblée générale de l'onu
accueille la république fédérale
d'allemagne et la république
démocratique allemande
l'admission se fait par acclamation il a
fallu 28 ans pour en arriver à ce
résultat historique
la construction du mur de berlin en 1961
avait entraîné une longue suite
d'incidents entre les deux allemagnes
béton et barbelés ne sont pas toujours
parfaitement hermétique
malgré la surveillance constante des
vopos toutes sortes de ruses sont
utilisés pour franchir le mur mais les
tentatives d'évasion se terminent
fréquemment de façon tragique
pourtant à partir de 1969 s'amorce un
processus de détente entre les deux
allemagnes une longue chaîne de
négociation et de traiter à moscou à
varsovie à berlin aboutira à cette
cérémonie impensable quelques années
auparavant monsieur walter schels pour
la république fédérale
monsieur choupette pour la république
démocratique allemande paraphes
le 20 juin dernier à la chancellerie de
bonnes le traité fondamental
intégralement
c'est la consécration de la division de
l'allemagne
mais en même temps c'est l'entrée
officielle de ces deux allemagnes sur la
scène internationale pour la première
fois dans une grande conférence
multilatérale les deux états allemands
sont représentés à helsinki pour la
conférence sur la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
messieurs walter schels pour l'ouest
monsieur otto witte heures pour l'est
depuis hier soir l'ordre alphabétique
sépare d'une travée les deux allemagnes
aux nations unies